Okay, welcome to this workshop on MCP
agent fine-tuning. I'm Ronan from the
Trellis Research YouTube channel and
today I'll be showing you how to run an
agent that has access to tools via MCP
servers and then take traces or logs
from the highquality runs and use them
to fine-tune and improve the performance
of a model. By the end of the workshop,
you should be able to generate
highquality MCP agent reasoning traces.
Save the tools and the multi-turn traces
from each of those runs. Fine-tune uh a
model. I'm going to show you how to
fine-tune Quen 3, but you'll be able to
fine-tune other models, too. And then
run the fine-tuned model and see if the
performance uh is any better. Now, all
of the materials are available online in
this repo here, Trellis Research AI
Worlds Fair 2025, and they're in the MCP
agent fine-tune
folder. I'll be cloning this and working
through it very shortly, but first, I do
want to give a brief introduction to
what MCP is. That's model context
protocol. How it allows a language model
access to tools and I'll emphasize what
we need to understand about those
interactions when we're building both
the fine-tuning scripts and also the
agent scripts and saving of those logs.
So what is MCP model context protocol?
It is a protocol for providing services
to LLMs namely access to tools. The tool
we're going to focus on is browser use.
So using an LLM to navigate through
websites, but there are MCPS for things
like Stripe, GitHub, Gmail, and many
more you can find. You can sub those
into these examples today, but I
recommend running through first using
the MCP tool that I've selected until
you're comfortable with how everything
works. MCP does a few things. It's first
of all a store of information on tools.
That information helps the LLM to know
how it can make calls to the tools or
make use of them. But the MCP tool
service also runs the tools. So when the
LLM decides to make a call, MCP the tool
service will take the action whether
that's adding numbers or navigating to a
page and it will then return a response
which contains details of the result or
maybe some extra helping guidance for
the LLM. So the LLM can then loop back
and make another tool call or provide
some kind of textbased response.
Now to bring it to one more level of
detail, we're going to wrap the language
model here or we're going to expose it
in the form of an API that we can hit
and we're going to expose it as an
OpenAI endpoint which is um pretty
common. Of course, it's the one OpenAI
itself uses, but using that library,
there are many models and many libraries
that will make use of that style of API
endpoint if you want to set up an
endpoint for your language model. So
this is what we're going to use. And in
integrating this API endpoint, there are
a few points of integration or
translation we need to take care of.
Don't worry if you don't understand this
first time around because it'll become
apparent in the code. The first one is
we will get tool information from the
MCP services and we need to convert that
into lists of JSON tools because that's
what OpenAI endpoints expect. Second of
all, we will need to convert the tool
response into a format that the language
model expects. And lastly, when we have
uh the language model calling a tool and
it will call it just by emitting tokens
or text, we need to extract detect and
extract whether it wants to make a tool
call or not. And the form that the text
will take when it wants to make a cool
tool call is going to be uh in Hermes
format actually even though it's a Quen
model. And I'll talk about that uh in
just a little bit. To give you a better
idea of how all of this fits together,
it's helpful to look at a prompt. We can
take a look at um this little chat I've
prepared. It just shows a little pseudo
prompt. It's the string that is being
sent into the LLM. It starts off with a
system message just after a system start
tag. And it starts by describing to the
LLM how to make tool to tool calls
namely by passing them as JSONs within
these tool XML tags
here. And the LLM is being told okay you
have access to deal to these tools.
There'll only be one in our case which
is the browser. Please return each
function call as JSON inside tool call
tags if you wish to call a function. So
this is we're telling the LLM here's how
to call a a tool by giving us these XML
tags and then the
JSON. After the system message, we have
the first user message which would be
the first message like navigate to
trellis.com. And then the assistant will
respond and it can respond in a few
ways. Typically, it might do some
thinking here because it's a thinking
model and then decide to call uh some
tool like navigating with the browser to
a certain URL or if it's finished
navigating, it might decide to think and
then just provide an assistant response
as text. So, this is a little pseudo
prompt here. And we'll see this come
into play in the code when we want to
set up and inject these different parts.
Okay, so that brings me to the end of my
very quick overview of MCP and the
prompt structure. If you're not
following fully, that's okay because
it'll become a lot more clear when I run
the examples, which I'll do now by
cloning this repo AI worlds fair into
Windsurf. If you clone it, you want to
open up then the MCP agent fine-tune
folder and go to the readme. Now, in
this readme, there are two sections.
There's the data collection section
where we run the agent to generate these
sample runs. And then there's the
fine-tuning which will be done in a
notebook. So starting off with the data
collection, we need to make sure we have
an endpoint. We need to make sure it's
an OpenAI style endpoint. And if we're
not using OpenAI itself, which we won't
be because I'm going to generate the
traces using a Quen type agent because
I'm going to fine-tune a Quen model
later. I do recommend keeping some
consistency between the model to
generate data and the model you're going
to fine-tune. In principle, you could
just use a stronger model, any stronger
model. Um, but we want the stronger
model to share its reasoning traces so
we can train on those. And OpenAI models
don't share their thinking traces. So,
we're going to use Quen model.
Specifically, we're going to use the 30
billion parameter one with uh 3 billion
activated uh parameters. It's a mixture
of experts model. And I'm going to run
it on RunPod. I'm going to use this
oneclick affiliate template here. You
can run it though on any service. In
principle, I think you could run it
locally as well, provided local uh your
local app supports tool calls. I'd need
to look into whether LM Studio does uh
support that. But if you click that
oneclick link, you'll pick a GPU, maybe
a
H100, and you can inspect then the
template. So, a few things here. We're
running a Docker image for VLM. We're
running this Quen model. We're going to
enable reasoning and a reasoning parser.
What this means is that when we see a
response that includes think tokens,
we're going to detect those and extract
it as reasoning into a JSON uh type
style in the response. Next, we're going
to set the max model length to 32,000.
We'll set the port. We're going to host
it on port 8,000. And we're going to
enable automatic tool choice. This means
the LLM will decide whether or not to
call a tool and which tool to call. Here
we have the tool parser that we're
choosing. You'll remember in my
presentation I said we need to specify
how to extract the tool into JSON
format. What this means is when the LLM
makes a tool call like this, we're
saying okay the tool call is in this
format. Hermes extract it into this JSON
here and provide it to the MCP in a
format it's expecting. So this is
specifically this point here where it
converts from the language model string
into a JSON format that OpenAI uh the
API expects. Okay, so these are all of
the arguments we'll use and then we
click here to start the server. We do
need need to expose port 8000 because
that's where we're serving it. We're
going to hit that port and server from
outside. And the way we're going to hit
it, by the way, I would click set
overrides and start the server. I
actually have a server that's running
already here. It will take about 3
minutes to start up. And to hit the
server, we need to specify the runpod
pod ID and also the port number, which
is 8,000. So you'll see here when we run
this agent, and I'm going to start just
by running it without explaining it, cuz
it'll be more intuitive when you see an
example. I'm going to run the agent with
this model here. I'm going to run it
with this base URL, which has got the
pod ID and the port number, and it's got
the V1 that is required for the OpenAI
style endpoint. And there's one more
argument here I'm using which is
truncate. This is truncating the length
of the tool response. So when you have a
tool response for example here there's a
tool response coming back. If we call a
browser navigate tool to navigate to
trials.com it's going to return an
accessibility tree which is a text
description of that page and that will
be provided back in the tool response so
the language model can read the page.
But this could be really long and so I'm
just naively truncating it. So we just
take the top part. Now bear in mind that
means that the LLM won't probably be
able to see the full length of the page
and you would need to do something more
complex uh in a deeper implementation of
what I'm
showing. So we're going to run the agent
here and first run UV sync just to make
sure you've synced the requirements. If
you don't have UV, do pip install UV and
then you can run the agent here.
So you'll see the agent has started up.
We've started the MCP server. This is
the only server that's configured and
it's configured in the config file here.
You can add in other servers here and it
will load up those tools. Playright
offers 25 tools. So there's quite a few
like I think navigate forwards,
backwards, switch tab, navigate to link,
different things like this. We'll see
more of them later. And those 25 tools
are all available to the LLM. For open
source models, probably you don't want
more than maybe 25 to 50 tools. I think
for claude, you can probably handle 200.
More than that, the LLM will get
confused by a lot of uh
context. So now it's asking me to put in
an input. And I'm going to say navigate
to
trellis.com and read out the top two
lines. Let's see what it does with that.
It should start to think now. That user
message has gone to the LLM. It should
be thinking now. Generating thinking
tokens. They won't be shown here just
for brevity. I'll save them later on.
And then yeah, it's asking for a tool
call to move and navigate to trials.com.
Okay. And actually before I say yes to
that tool, which uh requires my
approval, I'm just going to put this
screen on the side. So I leave space
here cuz the browser is going to pop up.
And the reason the browser will pop up
is because I'm running this browser. Uh
I'm not running it in headless mode. If
you want the browser to operate in the
background, you would just put in d-
headless. But I actually want to do it
because I want to see the browser and
what it's doing. So I'm going to um I'm
going to ask this uh question here,
which is
navigate
to
trails.com and read out the top two
lines. Okay. So I'm expecting the model
to start thinking here. The tokens won't
be printed because I'm saving them just
to avoid clutter on the screen. And then
yeah, it's decided to call a tool which
is triles.com navigate there. I've built
in approval to the agent. So I'm going
to say yes. And now it has opened up
that browser which is good. And the
structure, the accessibility structure
should be sent now to the LLM. And it is
picking out uh the top line here. And
it's also picking out this second line
here. So this looks really good. I'm
just going to exit. And that was our
first uh quick
demo. So I've got a few little demos
here. I'm just going to clean up two
demos uh from before where I didn't have
my screen set up. And you can see the
logs here. So I've got a feature where
by default when you run the agent things
are going to be logged uh like this with
two parts with the messages part and a
tools part. And this is exactly what we
need for fine-tuning. We need to know a
list of the tools and we need the full
conversation history. So you'll see in
the tools a list of the 26 browser close
browser resize etc. And under messages
you can see my user
request. Then the assistant starts
thinking and yeah there's quite a bit of
thinking. User wants me to navigate to
trials.com etc etc. So it goes through
all this logic and then it decides to
make a tool call here. The tool call is
sent to the MCP and then playright
basically opens that up as you saw and
sends back the accessibility trace which
includes details on the page but
truncated and then the assistant takes
that and says oh I have the information
I need here's some reasoning and here's
my final answer. So this is a very nice
trace and we're going to keep it. We're
going to keep it and we're going to use
this for fine-tuning. Now, it wouldn't
make sense to fine-tune using this on
the same model because the model can
already do this, but it can make sense
to fine-tune a smaller model that
doesn't have uh this kind of capability.
So, your goal now is you should set this
up and you should run this and I want
you to run it multiple times and try to
get some good traces and then we'll save
those traces and we're going to upload
them to hugging hugging face hub. Okay?
So, we'll run one more example here. I'm
going to make it a bit more complicated
this time and I'm going to say navigate
to trellis.com and then find the third
product. Navigate to that page and tell
me what is on
um you know what let's try and ask a
specific question. So let's go to
trellis.com and manually do the
navigation first. Oops. Oh, I can't
type. Here we go. Trellis.com. The third
model is training and fine-tuning. We'll
navigate there. It opens in a new tab,
which by the way is tricky for
navigation. And let's ask it uh what the
first line is. Yeah, let's ask what is
in the features section. Okay, we'll try
that. So, the model should be thinking.
We should see the browser pop
up in a second. Once we approve that
navigation, it should get a
snapshot and we'll see what it decides
to do next. It should try to do this
drop-own menu here, which is a bit
tricky. It is clicking on something. So,
that's good. It did get the drop-own
menu. That's also good. And okay, it's
actually just given an answer, which is
not exactly what we want. Yeah. Well,
the answer is correct. It says, do you
want to click the learn more section?
Yes, click that and then navigate.
Um, and then make sure to switch tabs
because it will open in a new tab. So,
yeah, I mean, this is kind of working
out well. There's always going to be
noise, so some of the traces won't be
good. And I'll show you some ways to
deal with that. One is to just manually
adjust the trace. All right, it's going
to click on learn more. And that has
opened a new tab, which is
good. And now it's going to think. It's
thinking in the background. We'll save
the thinking logs. And it's asking to
select that uh tab too, which is this
tab. And I think at this point it'll get
a browser snapshot, but I'm not entirely
sure of that. And let's see. So it
um the core features are GitHub repo
access and ability to post issues. So
yeah, this is correct. Um it's getting
the correct content. So it's actually
fulfilled this task very well. And I'm
going to
exit. Now before I show you the trace,
there's one more trick. If it's not
following what you wanted to do, you can
kind of guide it like I did in the user
prompt and adjust retrospectively. But
you can also pass in a system prompt. So
you could pass in a system prompt like
this that literally explains very
directly how it should do this task and
what tools to call. And this can also
help performance. And the idea is you
get it to create a nice tidy trace and
then you don't have to include the
system prompt in your training data. you
just train on that nice trace because
our goal is to get nice traces for for
training data. So, I'll just show you
that and then you should go yourself and
try to make some of these different
traces. Let's find that more complex one
which I just made. Let's see if I want
to make some adjustments here. So, we
have the tools that are saved and I'm
I'm not going to change those. But right
here when I say
uh make sure to switch
tabs. Um let's just expand at thinking.
I need to find I'm trying to find the
section where I said yeah click that and
yeah. Okay. So one thing you could do is
literally delete that user turn and
combine and combine kind of these two
sections here. Obviously you could kind
of do that manually or just literally
copy paste it into chat GPT and ask chat
GPT to generate uh just a single
version. You would need to delete the
assistant content just provide
reasoning. Um but another approach here
is just to say uh yes click that and
proceed.
Um, and instead of saying and switch to
a new
tab, I may then need to switch tabs if
it opens in a new
tab. So, you can see I'm cleaning up the
trace here. And yeah, this is some nice
data. So, we have a few data points that
I've saved. And what we want to do now
is push this up uh to to hub. So we want
to create a data set that has the tools
and that has the conversations that
we'll use for fine-tuning. So for that
I'm just going to run push to hub. And
quite simply it's going to grab the
tools and it's going to grab the the
messages and push them up to a data set.
Now there's one subtle point here that
I'll show you which is called uh
unrolling the data because we want to
train on multiple turns not just the
first response but the second and the
third. So actually if we have say three
back and forths we want to unroll that
into three rows. One row with all of
them, one row with just two and one row
with one. So actually we get kind of
three for the price of one in terms of
of training data here. And there is a
subtle point that the template of Quen
will always include the reasoning from
the most recent turn. So even if we
include reasoning and save it for all of
the turns, it will only inject the most
recent reasoning. And that's another
reason why doing this unrolling is
important. uh ask me a question in the
comments uh if you want more
clarification on that. It's kind of a
subtle point. If you want to push to
hub, you can just look up uh in the
readme there's a function here push to
hub. You need to specify the repo ID and
then pass in unroll if you want to do
that
unrolling. And this data set uh should
get pushed up. Now I do need to uh log
into hugging
face. So I'm just going to do that. So
I've put in my uh my token. It needs to
have right permissions and then I can
run push to hub again. And it's a pretty
small data set. There's nine examples.
So it's unrolling these four into nine.
One of them has three, the others have
two when unrolled. And then I can check
out my data set which has got um ID time
stamp the model the messages and then
the tools. And you can see uh I think
there's also a flag whether it's been
truncated which means unrolled. So say
this last example
uh well it's not the last example but
there's an example here where we have
unrolled it twice. So the first example
here, second example, third example has
got two it's got three turns. So there
are two unrolls. So you'll see if you
look at the messages here this will give
the full three
turns. So it'll be fairly long. It will
have all of the messages. And notice how
the reasoning content is extracted.
That's because we've turned on the
reasoning parser. But if we scroll right
down to the bottom of this, and I know
it's kind of long, that's because the
tool responses are long. You can see the
last response is the answer, or at least
it should be. Yeah, it's saying what's
on that page. Whereas, if you go up to
the one above that where it's been
truncated,
um, it should just be a tool call, I
think. Or it may actually be that
assistant response we got. Uh yeah, it's
uh got some reasoning content and then
it's making a tool call down here where
it's deciding to select the tab. So you
can see we've got nine rows of data here
and we will grab these messages and we
will template them along with the tools
in our fine-tuning template uh when we
want to fine-tune the model which we're
going to do very shortly now. Okay. So
at this point, you should be able to go
ahead and run this a few times, try to
modify some of the traces, try to push
some of that data up to
hub. I will maybe very briefly show you
the agent.
Um, let me see how I can do this
quickly. I'm basically setting up an
OpenAI endpoint.
Um, and what can I say that won't be too
long? I need to set up the servers. So I
have server management here. Any MCP
service that I want to run, I need to
boot it up when I start the agent. So
that's one of the first
things I need to do schema conversion
then. So I talked about how you have MCP
that has a specific syntax, but OpenAI
expects the endpoint expects a different
syntax. So there's conversions that need
to happen. There are some kind of helper
functions, but then here's how we
convert the t the tools from MCP to the
OpenAI format. And then we need to go
OpenAI to MCP. So we need to go both
directions. Here's where we execute the
tools. And here's how we wrap the result
in a format that's going to be suitable
for OpenAI. So that's all those
connections I showed you in the
PowerPoint. This here is discovering all
the tools, then booting up the servers.
And this is the chat loop which you saw
operating below. There's not a whole lot
that's uh to explain beyond what you saw
me doing. You can see reasoning has been
parsed separately to the assistant
content.
Um,
and we have a helper here for trace
logging just to save the details. And
yeah, we have some logic here for for
doing the logging and then some
different uh some different arguments
that we can pass. So, I'll let you dig
on that in your own time. In the
meantime, let's move to the finetuning
step. So, we've got these traces and we
want to use them to improve the
performance of the LLM. We'll go to the
fine-tuning section and open up this
notebook. I have it open here. Uh my
runtime is disconnected. I'll just
restart. This is based on an Unslaught
notebook for fine-tuning Quen, but it's
got some things that I've
changed. First thing we'll do is install
Unslo, which has got a bit more of a
detailed detailed install if you're on
Collab. And then we'll load a model. Now
I'm going to train the 4 billion
parameter model. You can train a larger
model if you want better performance.
The max sequence length needs to be
fairly large. If you want to train on
the free GPU, you probably can't train a
larger model. Um, you'll need to run
maybe on run podge by starting up. You
can find a fine tuning oneclick template
actually in the oneclick lm's repo. You
can start that up and then open Jupiter
and then open the download the notebook
here and upload
it. We're going to run it in full
precision in 16
bits. And once we've loaded the model,
we'll want to set it up for training.
We're actually not going to train all
the parameters. We're going to only
train adapters that we connect to
certain parts, certain matrices. They're
called uh low rank adapters or Lora. And
I'll talk about applying those adapters
in a moment. But I want to actually get
a benchmark on performance without
fine-tuning. So I'm not going to apply
the Laura adapters just yet. I'm going
to prepare the data and then I'm going
to run inference without having done
fine-tuning. And the data we're going to
load is that data set that we've been
looking at right here. So we load it up
and we'll just print it out to see how
many rows. It should be nine rows.
Now, if you want, you can take a look at
uh the format of the messages or the
tools just by running these to inspect
the zerooth row. You can also take a
look at the chat template. Uh the
template is what takes in the tools and
the messages and puts it into a single
long string. In fact, it's probably
worth looking at. So, we just run that.
You can also find it if you go to the
model. You can go to the tokenizer
config on the model on hugging face and
you can see a copy of that there as
well.
By the way, um, my runtime restarted, so
I need to redownload the model weights
and they're just downloading here. It'll
take a few moments. And yeah, as I said,
we take a look here at the data set.
Sorry, I've got a really long data set
row
saved. Once we have the data set
downloaded, which means we're going to
have access to the messages and the
tools, we basically pass them into the
chat template, which will make a single
long string. And that single long string
is basically this. It's the formatted
data set as a single long string. And it
is very long because it contains all of
those uh tool responses. But you can see
it starts off with a system message. It
starts off with those tools. It then
gives a list of the tools available
which is very long. There's 26 of them.
Then it'll give the user message, the
assistant message, the tool calls,
etc. So that's uh what it's going to
look like. When we rerun this, we will
have nine rows. And then we'll just
print out to check what the length of
the longest row is because we don't want
it to be longer than 32,000 which is our
max length. Um so we'll do a check
there. Now we will train the model but I
said first we'll just do a quick run to
see how performance is without training.
And for that we'll just run on the first
row of the data set and we will see if
the model decides to call a tool
correctly when I ask it to navigate to
um
trellis.com.
So yeah, if we print out
um yeah, if we print this out, we should
start to get it to uh stream a response.
Here's one I streamed earlier with a
fine-tuned model and it correctly called
a tool. But if I if I call this again
now, let's just quickly check the length
of the data set. Oh, the data set is not
defined. Why is that? I don't think I
ran all of my data set
rows. So let's just check downloaded
data
set. All these rows will run quickly.
It's a quite small data set. Yeah, nine
rows. The longest is 18,000. That would
be
fine. And yeah, you can see if I print
out the zeroth message, I'm asking it to
navigate to
trials.com. And if I run inference on
that, it should just start to stream its
output string. and we'll see whether it
decides to call a tool or not. So we're
just testing here the raw 4 billion
parameter model which should be capable
of tool calling. This is a lot of tools
for a 4 billion parameter model though
26 tools. So you know it's going to blab
on here with a lot of thinking and then
we'll check whether it gives a tool
call. It may or may not. It may decide
to blab on for a full 2,000 tokens and
then just stop when it hits the limit.
So we'll come back to this. But what
you're going to do now that this model
is loaded is you're going to prepare it
for fine-tuning by applying Laura
adapters. And we're going to apply Laura
adapters to the attention modules and
also to the MLP layers. We will use a
rank of 32 which means the adapter
matrices will uh have effectively a
width or height of 32. We'll use uh
rescaled Laura which will adapt the
learning rate of the Laura adapters
according to their size. Larger Laura
adapters means lowering lower learning
rate. Uh, so I'll go ahead and apply
that. The data should all be prepped. So
we can go right to training the model
here. We're going to pass in the data
set and it's going to train based on the
text field because we've prepared that
text field. I went through this quickly,
but if you recall when we formatted the
messages and the tools, we templated
them into one string of text. That's the
text key there. And when we did that, we
essentially prepared it so we could pass
in just rows of text to our trainer
batch size of one. This is not ideal
because you don't get much uh smoothing.
It's going to make it very jumpy in
training loss, but we don't have enough
VRAM here. If you run on an A40 or on a
H100, you'll have more VRAM. So, you can
use a larger batch size. We just train
for one epoch. Um, we actually shouldn't
have warm-up steps because we don't have
enough steps here at all. If I have nine
rows, I'm only going to have nine steps
with gradient accumulation one. device
batch size of one. Learning rate is
fairly high because it's a small model
using the AtomW 8 bit optimizer to save
a bit of VRAMm and we'll use a constant
learning rate. Everything here is quite
simple. Um I'll probably do a follow-up
video with some more advanced techniques
on the YouTube channel on the TR
research channel afterwards. Uh so keep
an eye out for that, but I wanted to
keep this fairly simple so we can go
through it uh quickly. So yeah, we'll
run the training. That's actually just
setting up the training. We'll check the
device memory. It's got uh 15 GB, 10 of
it's reserved already. And we can start
to train. After training, we'll show the
final code. And then we'll run inference
again. Now, let's just take a look at
what it did without training. And
actually pretty good. So on this basic
task here, um it more or less got the
problem correct. Would it be able to
read out the top two lines? Probably it
would even with the 4B model. But I can
tell you that if you do a more
complicated task like multistep um it
will struggle. It already struggled when
we did the 30B model as I showed you. It
was kind of lucky I got it to work when
I did. Uh but this 4B model will
definitely struggle on
multi-step. So after the training, I'll
rerun that and we can see uh what it
does. Hopefully it'll also get it
right. You can see the training is
underway here. We've got nine steps.
We're only training 1.62% of the
parameters. So those adapters are tiny.
Everything else is frozen. All the main
weights are
frozen and it'll take a little bit of
time for this to complete and then
inference to run. And when that's done,
we've the option to save the model and
the
tokenizer. We also have the option then
to push the model up to hub. If you want
to do that, you can just log into
hugging face here and then I recommend
merging it to 16 bits. If you merge it
with this name here, for example, you
can actually go back into your pod. You
could edit the pod and just swap drop in
here the name of your fine-tuned model
and now you've got an inference endpoint
uh ready to go. So let's see how our
training is doing. About 2 minutes left
and our training loss is falling. You
know in a more advanced implementation
you would want to have an eval set. So
you want to have much more data not just
nine traces. You want to have probably a
few hundred. You want to split some of
those off into an eval set. You also
want to do logging with TensorBoard. I
go through that in most of my videos,
but uh I wanted to keep this fairly
simple. Okay, so we have the training
completed and generally the loss is kind
of falling. Like it's very bumpy and
that's it's not quite completed by the
way. It's just finishing up. But it's
not helped by the fact that we only have
batch size of one. Ideally, we'd have
batch size of like 32 maybe, which would
require quite a bit more data. um you
could use gradient accumulation, but if
you have a very small amount of data,
you actually just have to set the batch
size smaller. Um you don't want to do
just one update step with all of the
data. So we're kind of doing the best we
can here given uh the limited amount of
data and this is something you can
definitely add a lot more traces to
hopefully. Now just one other comment
because I know one question will be
around reinforcement learning. Can we
automate this so that we generate traces
automatically or use some reward-based
system? And my recommendation there is
start off with manual traces and curate
them like this because even if you want
to do rewards afterwards like GRPO and
you can check some of the other videos
on that, it's going to be beneficial to
SFT supervised fine-tune like I am now
on some traces that are high quality. If
you just start with a model that you
want to do reinforcement learning on,
but you've not done any supervised
finetuning for that domain, it's going
to struggle. it's going to generate lots
of traces and very rarely get to the
correct answer where it sees a positive
reward. So, it will speed up your
training a lot even if you do
reinforcement learning afterwards. Um,
if you first generate some high quality
traces and then do the finetuning. Now,
if you want to do GRPO, you need to
define rewards. That means you need to
have a data set where you have answers.
That could involve picking some random
niche websites and picking finding maybe
the text on the top and then asking the
language model to navigate to those kind
of obscure pages and then you have a
ground truth of what those lines of text
are. That's just a really simple
example, but you need to come up with a
way to systematically generate data
that's verifiably correct and then
reward the model when it gets that
answer correct. Okay, that was a bit of
a sidebar on reinforcement learning,
which is not the focus here, but it's
very much related. We have finished the
training. The loss I'd say generally has
has gone down. Uh we used peak memory
75%. So we didn't have space for
probably doing a batch size of two. And
now we're generating response. So the
model is
thinking and it's got about 2,000 tokens
to think. Let's see if it finishes up uh
with recommending a tool call. It may or
may not. It's possible that with this
noisy of a training, we bumped it off.
What was a good answer at least the
first time around? By the way, I'm using
default parameters for running
inference. You can set them manually
here. There's recommended parameters for
Quen for the thinking model. And yeah,
it looks good. It's calling the tool as
expected. So, you'd want to do a much
more elaborate setup on the evaluation.
You probably want to run your model on
the endpoint and actually try to run
some of the rollouts over in um the
workspace on Windsurf that I showed you
earlier. Just in case you want to see uh
what the default configuration
parameters are, you can see the
temperature is 6 and I think these are
the recommended parameters if you're
using uh a reasoning type model. Okay,
with that it brings us full circle.
Hopefully you've had an opportunity to
create some good traces and understand
now how to do fine-tuning at least in
principle even if we didn't use all that
much data. This is something you can
build on by adding in different MCP
servers, curating many traces, and I
think it's it's probably quite powerful
even without moving to RL. If you've got
a small number of examples, um, and I
mean maybe 100 or 50, something that you
can realistically generate yourself, I
think you can get uh significant
improvements in performance,
particularly if there are some kind of
narrow trees that are common uh, but
important for your use case. As I said
at the start, all of the materials are
in Trrow Research AI Worlds Fair 2025.
You might also want to check out the two
MCP videos that are on Trellis Research
on YouTube if you want to understand in
a bit more detail how those servers are
not just set up, but how you would make
a custom one by yourself. In the
meantime, any questions, uh, let us know
by posting down below in the comments.
Cheers, folks.